[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
ए
[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन
गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार आप लोग यह
कंफर्म कर दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज सुने
दे रही है नहीं दे रही चाट में प्लीज
जल्दी से बता दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू
तो हो आप सभी का स्वागत हमारे डिप्लोनिक्स
अकादमी के युटुब चैनल
इमेज ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस की इमेज के बेस
पर हम कैसे ओपन सोशल टेलिजेंस करते हैं
मतलब की हमें कोई इमेज मिलती है या इमेज
में कोई टेक्स्ट मिलता है चैत्र इमेज
क्लियर नहीं है तो उसके बेस पर हम कैसे
एनालिसिस करेंगे ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
कैसे करेंगे यह इमेज किसने ली होगी क्या
इसकी जिओ लोकेशन हो शक्ति है
कब ली होगी कहां की होगी एग्जिट को डिलीट
किया हो सकते हैं
थ्रू ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस ऑफ इमेज तो आगे
बढ़ते हैं इसी में हमारा दो दिन ओपन
इंटेलिजेंस देगा इमेज के ऊपर जिसमें हम
कुछ लैब कर करेंगे और आज से क्या है की
आपके कुछ टास्क मिलेंगे तो आपको क्या करना
है की और ताश पे क्या करना ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस रहेगी इमेज की तो आप पहले तो
आपको बताया गया है की
जो भी आपको क्या करना है की जो भी क्लास
में आप सिख रहे हो उसके क्या की आपने आज
की क्लास में क्या शिखा क्या टॉपिक था
हमारा किस से रिलेटेड था वो टॉपिक वो
साड़ी चीज आपको क्या करनी है की हमारे
लिंकडइन पेज पर जाना है हमारे लिंकडइन पेज
पर जाना जो युटुब चैनल हमारा इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में नीचे है लिखा हुआ है की
लिंकडइन लिंक है
वहां पर जाकर आपको क्या करना हमारा
डिप्रॉनिक्स का ऑफिशल पेज है वहां पर हर
दिन की क्या होती है की जो भी क्लासेस
होती है हमारी किसी भी टॉपिक पर वह वहां
पर अपडेट हो जाति है वहां पर जाइए आप
कमेंट कीजिए उसके थ्रू ही हमें पता चलेगा
ज्यादातर एक तो यहां पर 10 डेज है उधर
हमें पता चलेगा की कितने लोग एक्टिव हैं
कितने लोग कर कर रहे हैं उसके बाद जैसे ही
कोई भी आपको टास्क मिलेगा कुछ भी करने के
लिए कुछ भी किसी भी एनालिसिस करने के लिए
उसकी आपको क्या करनी है जैसे की आज दो
टास्क मिलेंगे आपको तो उसका आपको बेसिकली
करना क्या है पूरा फूल एनालिसिस करना है
आपको एनालिसिस करके उसे पे कुछ भी
मिसलेनियस नहीं करना उसमें पहले बात तो
उसमें कुछ मिसलेनियस करने के लिए है नहीं
बाय डी वे वैसे भी बोले वो लैब है फिर भी
आपको क्या ध्यान रखना है कुछ भी उसके साथ
इलीगल करने की कोशिश नहीं करनी है लेकिन
उन टास्क को क्या करना आपको एक रिपोर्ट
बनानी है कैसे कौन से स्टेप परफॉर्म किया
आपने क्या टूल उसे किया और आपने क्या
एनालिसिस किया आपने किया इस चीज में देखा
और कैसे आपने फाइंड आउट के रिपोर्ट बनके
आप क्या कीजिए उसको चाहे वो आप वन नोट में
बनाया चाहे किसी भी चीज में बनाया उसे
उसको बनाकर आप क्या करो अपने गूगल ड्राइव
के लिंक में रखो उसके बाद आपको फरदर शेर
करने के लिए रूप में मिल जाएगा की आपको
कहां पर शेर करना है बेसिकली आपको शेर
करना ही होगा गूगल ड्राइव लिंक भी आप आपको
कहां शेर करना होगा हमारे
लिंकडइन पेज पर ही करना होगा उसके बाद
क्या की आपके साड़ी चीज देखने के बाद आपके
पास आपकी अटेंडेंस आपके परफॉर्म देखने के
बाद जैसे ही हमारा 10 दिन पूरे हो जाएंगे
उसके बाद हम दो से तीन दिन में एनालिसिस
करेंगे आप लोगों का और आपको एक जो लकी गे
है जो लकी होगा आप लोगों में से उसको उसके
बड़े में उसको मैसेज मिल जाएगा और उसको
ओबवियसली अनाउंस कर देंगे कौन था हमारा
लकी विनर ऑफ डी टी-शर्ट ऑफ डी दिस देवर
रोनित कर ओके तो
स्लाइड में चलते हैं तो क्या सीखने वाले
हैं पूरे आज जो आपका जो इमेज और सेंड है
उसमें सीखोगे आप की हो तू डू इमेज रिवर्स
की एक इमेज है उसको रिवर्स सर्च कैसे
करोगे हो तू फाइंड आउट एक्जीबिट डाटा और
माते ऑफ अन्य इमेज किसी भी इमेज का
एग्जीक्यूट डाटा कैसे फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं अगर वो प्रेजेंट है तो हो तू जिओ
लॉकेट ओपन इमेज इमेज को कैसे जिओ लॉकेट
करोगे हो तू जिओ लॉकेट ओपन वीडियो वीडियो
को कैसे जिओ लॉकेट कर सकते हो हो तू फूल
टेक्स्ट आउट ऑफ अन्य इमेज की कई बार ऐसी
इमेज होती है जिनके अंदर टैक्स टैक्स होता
है जो या तो सिंपल भाषा में आपको समझ में
ए जाए तो बहुत ही आसन बात होती है कई बार
ऐसे टैक्स होते हैं जो आपको नहीं समझ में
आते तो उसके लिए कुछ टूल्स होते हैं कुछ
सर्च इंजन ऑटोमेटिक के लिए ही निकाल देते
हैं तो वो कैसे आप कर सकते हो दूसरा सबसे
मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट है और काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
फैक्ट है और काफी टाइम कंजूमिंग भी है
और मेरे लिए भी काफी चैलेंजिंग है यह की
हो तू कैलकुलेट टाइम फ्रॉम ए शैडो मतलब
आपको कोई एक इमेज है जिसमें कोई शैडो है
परछाई है परछाई के बेस पर आप कैसे पता कर
सकते हो की ये इमेज किस टाइम पर खींची गई
होगी मतलब जी टाइम पर इस इमेज को लिया
होगा गया होगा उसे टाइम पर ये टाइम होगा
मतलब एक आइडिया हमें मिल जाएगा उससे तो
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं तो देखो इमेज रिवर्स के
बड़े में पढ़ेंगे सबसे पहले की नो मटर यू
आर और वेयर यू आर इन डी वर्ल्ड आईएफ यू
हैव इंटरनेट और योर डेली उसे डिवाइस
लैपटॉप्स है डेस्कटॉप हैं मोबाइल तो मैं
आप लिमिटेड इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हो लेकिन
उससे भी कर सकते हो बट क्या क्या लैपटॉप
से डेस्कटॉप हैं सभी के पास आज के टाइम
में तो यह सर कम आप घर बैठे बैठे पब्लिक
के लिए इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल इनफॉरमेशन क्या
कर सकते हो उसे कर सकते हो पता कर सकते हो
अब किसी भी इंटेलिजेंस में कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
क्वेश्चन होते हैं जो हमें हमेशा फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं चाहे वो
इंटेलिजेंस आपकी पुलिस की हो या किसी
इंटेलिजेंस एजेंसी की हो चाहे वो किसी भी
चीज की इंटेलिजेंस हो उसमें यह चेयर
क्वेश्चन होते हैं व्हाट वेयर बेसिकली
क्या है की आपके पास क्या कोई भी एक फोटो
है या कोई भी वीडियो है उसके बेसिस पे
आपके यही कर सवाल रहेंगे की व्हाट माइ बी
हैपनिंग इन दिस फोटो वेयर इसे आईटी
तो यह छोटे-छोटे क्वेश्चंस हैं जिनका आंसर
करना बहुत ही डिफिकल्ट होता है क्योंकि एक
इमेज के बेस पर या एक वीडियो के बेस पर इन
क्वेश्चन को फाइंड आउट किया इमेज कहां की
होगी किसने ली होगी कहां पर किसने कब कौन
इस चीज के लिए रिस्पांसिबल है तो वह साड़ी
चीज फाइंड आउट करना एक छोटी सी इमेज के
बेस पर वैसे बहुत ही टिकल टास्क है आसन
नहीं है उसमें ऐसा नहीं है की एक घंटे की
क्लास में बैठ के मैं एक करवा दूंगा ठीक
है ये तो लैब हैं इसमें मिल जाएगी लेकिन
रियल लाइफ आपको दो दिन तीन दिन वन वीक 10
दिन आपको ग सकते हैं ऐसी चीज इनफॉरमेशन
निकालना के लिए क्योंकि पूरा इंटरनेट आपको
सर्च करना पद जाएगा इस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन
कर सवालों को ढूंढने के लिए अब बात
नेक्स्ट बढ़ते हैं नेक्स्ट जो चीज सीखने
वाले हो की इंर्पोटेंस
अब जो इमेज का एक्सिम डाटा होता है या जो
मेटा डाटा होता है उसकी क्या इंर्पोटेंस
होती है देखो
भाई लुकिंग आते डी एग्जिट और मटर डेट ऑफ
इमेज वैकेंसी हिडन इनफॉरमेशन डेट में बी
लेफ्ट बिहाइंड बाई समवन तू आंसर
पॉसिबल थ्रू
एनीवायताते ऑफ इमेज का देखकर आपको वहां से
क्या कोशिश करते हो की कुछ हिडन इनफॉरमेशन
हो कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन ऑफ फिंगर प्रिंटिंग
की कुछ ऐसी इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन आपको
वहां पर देखने को मिल जाए की जो आपके
क्वेश्चंस हैं जो आपके कर क्वेश्चन है
उनकी तरफ क्या करें वो इंडिकेट करती है
उनमें से किसी एक क्वेश्चन का आंसर बने की
कोशिश करें
मोबाइल की इनफॉरमेशन मिल जाति है कई बार
क्या मिलता है की किस कैमरे ने उसको लिया
है वहां पर पिक्सल्स मिल जाते हैं कई बार
क्या होता है की वहां पर कुछ एक जहां पर
उसे इमेज को अपलोड किया हुआ किसी चीज को
तो वहां पर कोई डायरेक्टर ही मिल जाति है
डायरेक्ट किसी यूजर का नाम एक्सपोज हो
सकता है तो इस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन आपको
मेटल डाटा या एग्जिट डाटा से मिल शक्ति है
और
आगे चलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइन पर अब कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट तू रिमेंबर
आप ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस किसी भी टाइप्स
की करो चाहे आप किसी भी यूजरनेम के बड़े
में पता करो एबीसी भी ईमेल के बड़े में
पता करो फोन नंबर के बड़े में पता करो एवं
आप इमेज के थ्रू किसी भी चीज के बड़े में
पता करने की कोशिश करो आपको ये पॉइंट
हमेशा ध्यान रखना है इंटेलिजेंस के कैसे
में मेक डी ब्रीफ नोट एच और एवरीथिंग
व्हेन डूइंग अन्य टाइप ऑफ ओपन सोस
इंटेलिजेंस स्पेशली व्हेन वीविंग मेटल
डाटा और एक्जीबिट डाटा आईटी कैन बी एडिटेड
और हज बिन टेकन इन डी पेस्ट तू अटैक
डिफरेंट प्रॉपर्टीज और में बी एवं तू
मार्स और मिस लीडिंग ऑफ अवर इन्वेस्टिगेशन
विच लीड्स डेम तू ए रंग लोकेशन और नाम
ईटीसी सो कप्स इन मन मेक सर यू आर ऑलवेज
क्लोज फ्रेंड्स इनफॉरमेशन मतलब इस टाइप की
ये जो अंग्रेजी लिखी हुई है कितनी हार्ड
है नहीं बट मैं आपको समझा देता हूं देखो
क्या है जब भी किसी टाइप की आप इंटेलिजेंस
करते हो किसी भी चीज के थ्रू तो सबसे पहले
ही आपको क्या करना है आपने एक उसके हमेशा
नोट्स बना कर रखना है हमेशा जो भी आपको
इनफॉरमेशन रख दिया है आपको उन नोट्स में
लिखना ही पड़ेगा क्योंकि साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
आपको कौन से पेज पर कहा पर क्या इनफॉरमेशन
मिली आपको याद नहीं रहेगी इसलिए हर चीज का
आपको एक ब्रीफ नोट बना के रखिए किसी भी
सोच से आपको वो इनफॉरमेशन मिल रही है
स्पेशली मटर डाटा के कैसे में आपको क्या
ध्यान रखना है की जब भी आप मेड होके मेरा
मतलब क्या है की मतदा क्या हिडन इनफॉरमेशन
होती है की क्या होता है को बदला ले जा
सकता है अब हो सकता है की देखो आप जिसको
आप इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हो या जिसको आपके
बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन निकालना की कोशिश करो
हो सकता है की वो खुद से एक इंटेलिजेंस
में हो मुझे कोई ऐसा साइबर एक्सपर्ट हो या
खुद से कोई स्मार्ट हो क्योंकि मूर्ख
लोगों को तो ऐसा कम करते नहीं लेकिन
स्मार्ट ही होता है जिसके थ्रू आप
इंटेलिजेंस करते हो तो हो सकता है की उसने
क्या कर दिया की आपको मिसालिड करने के लिए
आपकी इन्वेस्टिगेशन को लीड करने के लिए
उसने वो इनफॉरमेशन डाली हो जो प्रेजेंट
नहीं हो लेकिन पेस्ट की हो सकता की 25 साल
पहले की वह इनफॉरमेशन उसमें डाली हो
क्योंकि वो पुरी इनफॉरमेशन चेंज करेगा तो
आप समझ जाओगे की हां इसने मटर डाटा चेंज
किया है ये तो मेरी इन्वेस्टिकेशन के साथ
मैच कर ही नहीं रहा अब हो सकता है वो क्या
करेगा की आप इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हो आप
अच्छे खेस ट्रैक पे चल रहे हो और आपको
मेटा डाटा मिल गया बस वो मेटा-टा आज से 4
साल पुराना है
लीड कर रहा है 4 साल पुरानी मित्रों के
लीड कर रहा है तो हमेशा आपको ध्यान रखना
है की जब भी क्या करते हो आप एक तो किसी
भी सिंगल सोर्स के भरोसे मत रहिए मल्टीपल
सोर्स से आपको इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट करनी है
हर एक का नोट्स बना के रखिए तो जहां भी जो
भी इनफॉरमेशन मिल रही है तो एटलिस्ट उसको
क्रॉस चेक कीजिए अगर आपको क्रॉस चेक कर
लोग तो ऐसा कभी नहीं होगा सारे प्लेटफॉर्म
से अलग डाटा निकलेगा आपको आपको से डाटा
कलेक्ट होगा कहानी से अलग मिलता है पता
चला की आपने मेरा डाटा में पिछले 4 साल की
इनफॉरमेशन लेकर घूम रहे उसके बेस में पता
चला उसमें कोऑर्डिनेटर भी एक्सपोज कर रखें
हैं और
आपको नाम भी एक्सपोज कर दिया आप उसे पर
रिसर्च बोला की मेरे को तो मिल गया सब कुछ
आप उसे पे लगे हो और आपने रिपोर्ट सबमिट
करवा दी पता चला की वो तो बहुत पुरानी
लोकेशन है और आपने अपनी रिपोर्ट के साथ
किया ही नहीं की और भी कोऑर्डिनेट्स मिले
हैं कहानी पर और भी कुछ लोकेशन मिली है और
भी कुछ ब्लू मिले हैं इन्वेस्टिगेशन में
तो वह साड़ी चीजों को ध्यान में रखना है
लेकिन आजकल क्या होता है की कोई भी इमेज
क्या होती है की आपसे व्हाट्सएप पे इसे
सोशल मीडिया पर अपलोड होती है तो बाय
डिफॉल्टर साड़ी वेबसाइट उसके मेटर-अटर को
क्या कहते हैं डिलीट कर देती है कभी भी आप
देखना की आपके मोबाइल का जो भी इमेज होगी
उसको आप देखोगे राइट क्लिक करके
प्रॉपर्टीज में उसमें भर भर के मिलेगा
लेकिन जैसे ही वो सोशल मीडिया पर जाति है
एवं फेसबुक ट्विटर इंस्टाग्राम व्हाट्सएप
कहानी पर भी जाति है तो उसका मेटल डाटा
बेसिकली चेंज हो जाता है
क्योंकि बहुत साड़ी वेबसाइट ऐसी है की
उसकी क्या कर देती है क्लीन कर देती है तो
यह वेबसाइट क्या करती है डाटा प्रोटेक्शन
की वजह से क्या करती है उसकी डाटा को
क्लीन कर देते हैं इसलिए डर हम बहुत कम
चांसेस होते हैं की इनफॉरमेशन आपको मिले
लेकिन हो सकता है की कोई वेबसाइट ऐसा नहीं
कर रही हो या हो सकता है की उसने बाय
मिस्टेक लिए डायरेक्ट कहानी पर शेर किया
हो उसे क्लिक को और वो क्लिक आपको मिल जाए
तो ये चीज बिल्कुल ध्यान में रखना नेक्स्ट
चलते हैं अब क्या होता है की हो तू
आईडेंटिफाई लोकेशन फ्रॉम ए फोटो और वीडियो
जिसको हम जिओ लोकेशन बोलते हैं की क्या
होता है की अगर आप किसी भी फोटो की या
वीडियो की वीडियो की मैं आज भी सिखाऊंगा
कल सिखाया नेक्स्ट क्लास में सिखाऊंगा बट
क्या है की आपके पास कोई फोटो है उसके बेस
पर उसके आधार पर आप कैसे उसको जिओ लॉकेट
करोगे किस टाइप की इन्वेस्टिगेशन करोगे
कुछ उसे समय क्या होता है की वैसे तो आप
क्या कैसे भी कर सकते हो जनरल साइंस में
बट क्या होता है की कुछ
है जो एक आम माइथॉलजी है जो मैंने भी किसी
से शिखा
तो आप लोगों को भी क्या करना है की
बेसिकली यह मेथड
भी हो सकते हैं माइथॉलजी में स्टेप में
आपके इससे भी ज्यादा क्या ए सकता है स्टेप
हो सकते हैं मैं मेरे कुछ स्टेप्स हैं तो
आपके इससे भी ज्यादा हो सकते हैं आप एड कर
सकते हो बट क्या है की वो कौन-कौन से
स्टेप्स हैं जैसे की कॉन्टेक्स्ट सबसे
पहले स्टेप्स होता है कॉन्टेक्स्ट दिस इस
एन वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट तू लुक आते डी
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ ए फोटो और वीडियो पर
एग्जांपल बाय डूइंग इमेज रिवर्स सर्च बाय
लुकिंग
आते ओके आते डी मटर डेट ऑफ डी इमेज वीडियो
ट्रिंग तू फाइंड पॉसिबल इनफॉरमेशन
इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट डी इमेज ऑफ वीडियो
स्लाइड में आई एम सॉरी पर डेट
कांटेक्ट का मतलब क्या होता है की देखो
क्या करना है आपको जो जनरल इनफॉरमेशन मिल
रही है इमेज रिवर्स सर्च करके या उसके
एक्सिम डाटा को देखकर जो भी आपको
इनफॉरमेशन मिल रही है जनरल इनफॉरमेशन उसको
जितनी ज्यादा से ज्यादा आप क्या कर सकते
हो उसको सर्च कर सकते हो वो इनफॉरमेशन के
नोट्स बना लीजिए इनफॉरमेशन को क्या करना
है आपको फाइंड आउट करना है डोंट वारी
प्रैक्टिकल होगा ये थोड़ी आप लोगों के हैं
ना की किसी चीज को आप इन्वेस्टिगेट करने
जा रहे हो किस चीज के बड़े में आप जन जा
रहे हो तो उसके बड़े में आपको पता भी होना
चाहिए कौन-कौन से स्टेप लेने वाले हो
क्योंकि क्या होता है की जब आपके पास
मेट्रोलॉजी और आपके पास एक अप्रोच नहीं है
ना तो आप ब्लाइंड्ली इन चीजों को करोगे
आपका टाइम वेस्ट होगा थॉट्स भाई क्या है
ज्यादा डर का नहीं है बट क्या है की हम
थोड़ा सा क्या की आप एक अप्रोच वे में
चलेंगे तो सेकंड स्लाइड में चलते हैं अब
ये रहा अब क्या है की सेकंड पैथोलॉजी हम
उसे करते हैं 4 ग्राम व्हाट यू कैन सी इन
फ्रंट ऑफ डी फोटो अब आपके पास एक फोटो है
आपके पास एक पिक्चर है एक इमेज है
उसका फोर डॉ में देखिए की उसके प्रोग्राम
में क्या-क्या है क्या-क्या चीज हैं आपको
कोई स्ट्रिप दिखाई दे रही है कोई गली
दिखाई दे रही है कोई सड़क दिखाई दे रहा है
सड़क पर कोई पट्टी बनी हुई है या पास में
कोई डॉग है या कोई ऐसा सिंबल है कोई
ट्रैफिक सिंबल है या कोई फ्लैग है या कुछ
भी है फोरग्राउंड को देखने की कोशिश की है
उसको नोट डॉ कीजिए की फोर ग्राउंड को
हाईलाइट ये फोर ग्राउंड में आपने देखा
तो बैकग्राउंड देख रहा है आईटी इसे डी
मोस्ट इजीएस गिव अवेज मोस्ट ऑफ डी जिओ
लॉगिन किसी अब बैकग्राउंड फिर उसका क्या
करना है की आपको बैकग्राउंड को एनालाइज
करना है बैकग्राउंड को देखना जिसके
बैकग्राउंड में क्या-क्या है कितनी बड़ी
बिल्डिंग है या
क्या कोई
पहाड़ है या कोई पार्क है या कोई ज है या
कोई पीछे कोई
ऐसा कोई जानवर है या कुछ ऐसी लोकेशंस है
जो उसको एक्सपोज कर शक्ति है उसके
बैकग्राउंड को भी ध्यान में रखना है किसी
भी इमेज के बन जो आप जिओ लॉकेट करते हैं
उसके बाद मैप मार्किंग आई है देखो मैपिंग
के लिए आसन नहीं है लेकिन क्या की आप
एग्जैक्ट शॉप का तो आपको पता नहीं लेकिन
एक तरफ आइडिया बना सकते क्योंकि यहां इसके
अभी हैंड में कोई पहाड़ी है ओके हां आपने
हिल्स देखा है क्या कोई रिवर्स ए रही है
ओके हां रिवर्स आगे क्योंकि उसके बेस पर
लगा सकते हो की ये लिवर बड़ी है छोटी है
या कोई ऐसी चीज जो मैप मार्किंग के लिए कम
आए
तो इस तरीके से मैप मार्किंग कर सकते हो
लेकिन फिफ्थ और फोरमोस्ट स्टेप्स जिसको हम
बोलते हैं वह होता है आपका ट्रायल और एरर
ट्रायल और एरर मतलब क्या है की आप हमेशा
किसी भी चीज को कई कोई भी इनफॉरमेशन हो
चाहे आप सिक्योरिटी फील्ड में हो
फैंटास्टिक फील्ड में हो कहानी पर भी हो
आपको हमेशा क्या करना है ट्राई करना है
ट्राई और एरर आपको वहां पे ट्राई करते ही
जैसे क्या है की एरर भी मिलेगी तो हमेशा
जब तक ट्राई करते रहो जब तक आपको पुरी
इनफॉरमेशन सही ना मिले क्योंकि कहानी ना
कहानी तो वो इनफॉरमेशन आपको मिलेगी कहानी
ना कहानी तो वो पब्लिकली एक्सपोज हुई ही
होगी ऐसा हो ही नहीं सकता की वो कहानी ना
कहानी एक्सपोर्ट कोई ना हो तो
यह चीज थी कुछ और नेक्स्ट लाइन पे चलते
हैं और एक मिनट
नेक्स्ट है ओके अब सबसे पहले एग्जांपल
लेते हैं देखो पहले बात तो जितने भी
एक्सरसाइज हैं ये कैसे ली गई है तो मैं वो
वेबसाइट आपको बता दूंगा उसे पर ओनली कुछ
एग्जांपल नहीं है उसपे बहुत ज्यादा
एग्जांपल्स वो अपडेट होती रहती है तो ये
भी मैंने क्या है वहीं से लिया है तो पहले
टास्क हम परफॉर्म करेंगे
नेक्स्ट ओके तो अब यह ध्यान से पढ़िए
इसमें क्या लिखा है ध्यान से पढ़िए इसमें
क्या लिखा इस एग्जांपल को हम कर करेंगे
अभी यह एग्जांपल क्या बोलना है देखो इन
अप्रैल 2017
रिसिप्ट अप
फाइंड आउट डी नाम ऑफ डी लोकेशन
आपको यहां लगता है की आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट
है चाट में फटाफट भेजिए क्या लगता है की
आपको आपके लिए आपको क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन
होगी देखो यहां पर कुछ चीज उसने एक्सपोज
कर दी पहले आपके पास कुछ इनफॉरमेशन है
जैसे एक आपके पास डेट है अप्रैल 2017 आपके
पास क्या है अप्रैल 2017 एक डेट है
उसके बाद आपके पास एक नाम है मोहम्मद
अब्दुला फॉर्मेट जो ऊपर से उसका
डेजिग्नेशन भी आपके पास वो क्या है
प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ सोमालिया मतलब आपके पास
देखो इनफॉरमेशन कैसे है
डेट है
और वो कहां से है प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ सोमालिया
उसके बाद इनफॉरमेशन क्या है
न्यूज़ एजेंसी पब्लिक दे फोटो
लिया है और वो पब्लिश कर दिया
कंट्रीज प्रेसिडेंट मतलब क्या है
ये
तुर्की के प्रेसिडेंट है एक इनफॉरमेशन
आपके पास ये है और मतलब आपके पास कितनी
इनफॉरमेशन मिली एक डेट है आपके पास ऊपर से
एक शहर है मतलब उसमें विजिट किया गया है
तुर्की में उसके बाद किसने विजिट किया है
प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ सोमालिया जिनका नाम ये है
उसके बाद किसके साथ विजिट किया है
तरक्की के प्रेजेंट के साथ विजिट किया है
तो अब वो फोटो चलते हैं ये रहा
यह वह फोटो है यह वह फोटो है जहां पर यह
हैंडसेट कर रहे हैं अब हमें नहीं पता
इसमें कौन से प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ तार्किक हैं
कौन से प्रेसिडेंट समय लिया यहां पर पहले
बात हमें नहीं पता हमें पास एक जस्ट फोटो
है अब इसके बेस पर हम पूरा लिक एनालिसिस
करेंगे और हम पहुंचने की कोशिश करेंगे की
जहां पर ये खड़े हैं इसका एग्जैक्ट
कोऑर्डिनेटर क्या होगा इसका एग्जैक्ट
कोऑर्डिनेटर क्या होगा पहले मैं बता देता
हूं की ये जस्ट पर एजुकेशन परपज ओनली है
किसी को भी हनी पहचाने के लिए नहीं है यह
हमने जहां से लिया है प्रैक्टिस एक्सरसाइज
के लिए उसे किया गया है हमारा कोई भी गलत
इंटेंशन नहीं है इसको इन्वेस्टिगेट करके
ओके तो चलो फिर हम फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं अपनी यूनिवर्सिटी गेट को
फोर्ड ले चलते हैं ओके तो यह आपकी फोटोस
सोफिया करके किसी ने एक वेबसाइट बनाई है
सोफिया संतोष काफी अच्छी इन्होंने ओपन सो
इंटेलिजेंस के प्रैक्टिस एक्सेस बनाई है
और इसने मलिक भी अच्छा कम रहे हैं वेरी
थैंक यू फ्रॉम डी साइड ऑफ डिप्रॉनिक्स
अकादमी क्योंकि इनके सारे ही हम किसी को
ओपन सोशल एजेंट की एक्सरसाइज में
प्रैक्टिस करवा सकते हैं एडरवाइज किसी भी
चीज को हम क्या करते हैं की ऐसे ही उसे
करते हैं तो इलीगल वे में कोई भी उसे पर
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट कर सकता है बट वेरी
थैंकफूल फ्रॉम डी डिप्रॉनिक्स टीम सोफिया
सेन पॉज किया आपने ये वेबसाइट बनाई है और
यहां पर आपने हमें प्रैक्टिस के लिए तास
दिए हुए हैं तो कोई भी जाके किसी भी टास्क
को कर सकते हैं पोज की जब एक्सरसाइज में
जाओगे तो ये भी यहां पर क्या है टोटल
18 टास्क है ये अपडेट होती रहती है तो
यहां जाके आप अपने प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हैं
तो जो हमारा टास्क है जो हमने उठाया ये
रहा से ये टास्क है तो हम इसको इमेज है
क्योंकि वो जो आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे
रहा होगा ये सोमालिया प्रेसिडेंट मिक्स
फर्स्ट इंटरनेशनल विजिट तू
तुर्की तो ये वो न्यूज़ है जो आपको दिखाई
दे रहे हो जिसके बेसिस पे आपको एनालिसिस
करना है चलो ठीक है हम करते हैं अपना
एनालिसिस स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी ये हमारे
पास ये वो फोटो है इसको एक बार हम डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं
इमेज रिवर्स सर्च कर सकते हैं देखो राइट
क्लिक करता हूं मेरे पास ऐसा टूल्स है
इसलिए कर का रहा हूं अदर वाइस मैं क्या
करता हूं आपके पास नहीं है
पहले से कर लेते हैं इसको से करते हैं
इसका नाम बताता हूं मैं अपना
एक्सरसाइज जीरो वन इस फोटो को मैंने ले
लिया और मैं यहां पर डाउनलोड
एक यह फ्लैग है मतलब एक और यह किसी कंट्री
का फ्लैग है ऊपर से क्या है की दो लोग हैं
मतलब दो प्रेसिडेंट हैं आपस में हैंड चेक
कर रहे हैं और एक चीज नोटिस कीजिए सामने
देखें इसका मतलब क्या की फोटोग्राफर क्या
है सामने है इनके बिल्कुल सामने है दूसरा
क्या देख सकते हो आप पीछे ये देखो ये पीछे
आपको कुछ दिखाई दे रहा होगा या कुछ शायद
दरवाजा है ये क्या है कोई एक बड़ा सा
दरवाजा है और ऊपर से क्या की ये काफी एक
बड़ी बिल्डिंग से है मतलब ये रहा मतलब या
तो कुछ ऊपर से मैच हुआ है तो इससे से हम
एक बेसिक एनालिसिस क्या कर सकते हैं की
देखना की ऊपर से क्या की दोनों बड़े लोग
हैं मतलब की प्रेसिडेंट है डेफिनेटली ये
जो जगह होगी काफी कॉन्फिडेंशियल जगह होगी
और काफी हाय सिक्योरिटी होगी हाय
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर होगी ऊपर से क्या की
कोई पब्लिक प्लेस नहीं है पब्लिक प्लेस
होता तो वो घूमते हुए मिलते हैं इतना
क्लीन इतनी साड़ी चीज इतनी साफ-सुथरी
दिखाएं
की दोनों कंट्री के अलग-अलग लगे हुए हैं
और ऊपर से क्या की जी हिसाब से ये इमेज
रिप्रेजेंट हो रही है सबसे कोई बिल्डिंग
दिखे रही कोई बड़ी सी बिल्डिंग है तो हो
सकता है कोई स्पेशल बिल्डिंग हो कोई
नॉर्मल बिल्डिंग तो होगी नहीं कोई होटल
होगा नहीं मतलब इससे हम आइडिया गैस क्या
कर सकते हैं कोई स्पेशल बिल्डिंग होगी
जितना जूम करके देखो इसके बड़े में क्या
कर सकते हैं बस ये लोगो को दिखाई दे रहा
है कुछ और मतलब ये लोगो दिखाई दे रहा है
और यह स्टार है तो सब यह भी आइडिया लगा
सकता
है
तो चलो ठीक है एक कम करते हैं अभी इसका
ओसियन करते हैं अभी चलो हम चलते हैं अपने
गूगल पे चलो नेक्स्ट न्यू पेज पे और हम
क्या करते हैं इमेज को यहां से जरा अपलोड
करते हैं हमने कहां पर जाना है आपको एक
मिनट फिर से मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यार
आपको ये गूगल दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पे एक
आईकॉन दिखाई दे रहा होगा इमेज रिवर्स सर्च
करने के लिए हम जाते हैं उसके बाद अपलोड
किया मैंने और एक्सरसाइज वन
गुड
करेगा इसमें क्या कर दिया अब ये क्या कर
रहा है
इससे कुछ रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन मिल रही है
आपको इमेज ओके तो फिर से फ्लैग है से ये
है से बिल्डिंग है से लोग हैं ओके ठीक है
इसको हम एक न्यू पेज ओपन कर लेते हैं
सेकंड मतलब नहीं है ये भी नहीं है क्योंकि
वो फ्लेक्स है नहीं ये नहीं है
आपको ट्विटर पे दिखाई दे रहा है वैसे इससे
भी हम आइडिया लगा सकते हैं न्यू पेज पे
ओपन करते हैं नेक्स्ट ये भी क्या है की
ओके देखो से इमेज है मटका
कुछ लगता नहीं कोई इंपॉर्टेंट इमेज दिखे
रही है मेरे को इससे रिलेटेड हां ये भी का
सकते हैं
बट
वे कांत अशोक
अलग है उसके बाद मतलब की कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
[संगीत]
से म्यूजिक इमेज चलो ठीक है
यह भी है तो यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा बाकी और
कुछ नहीं काफी कुछ है
अभी ये देखो यहां पे कॉन्सेप्ट होता है
आपको चीज बताता हूं मैं की अभी यहां पर
देखो आपको कुछ समझ में नहीं ए रहा की ये
क्या लिखा हुआ है क्योंकि इसको ही
लैंग्वेज होगी
हां ये फोटो वही होगी
लेकिन हमें कुछ समझ में नहीं ए रहा है
देखो फोटो ये दोनों लोग वही हैं
प्रेसिडेंट ऑफ डी फोन
मैच कर रही है
मतलब फोटो का थोड़ा सा और व्यू ए गया
हमारे पास क्लियर ओके इमेज
ए रहा है देखो एक चीज टॉपिक समझता हूं
आपको यहां पर मैं सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक
क्या होता है चलती रहेगी साथ के साथ हम
करेंगे एनालिसिस देखो क्या होता है
ये अपनी इंग्लिश लैंग्वेज नहीं है तो आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा ट्रांसलेटर
बिल्कुल एंगल मिल सकता है आप लोग साथ में
करते रहो अपने साथ ओके तो देखो अभी यहां
पर क्या है की अब इस लैंग्वेज में समझ में
नहीं ए रहा है तुम इसको क्या करूंगा की
इसको मैंने क्या कर दिया मेरे पास क्या
मैंने एक एड किया होगा गूगल ट्रांसलेटर
क्योंकि एक मेरे पास मैं आपको बताऊं आप
क्या करो एक ये है आपका क्या बोलते हैं
गूगल क्रोम ट्रांसलेटर
गूगल
क्रोम ट्रांसलेटर
ट्रांसलेट गूगल क्रोम ट्रांसलेट यह रहा यह
एक्सटेंशन आप एड कर सकते हो शो डेट की जब
आपको इजी हो जाएगा क्योंकि मैंने अपने
इसमें एड किया हो तो रिमूव कर सके यहां पर
एड करने के लिए आएगा तो आप अपनी मशीन में
गूगल क्रोम ट्रांसलेट एड कर लीजिए तो अब
ये क्या है कई बार क्या होता है की आपके
सामने ऐसी सिचुएशन आएगी की आप को जो
रिजल्ट चाहिए होता चाहिए होगा वो उसे
लैंग्वेज में नहीं मिलेगा उसे लैंग्वेज
में नहीं मिलेगा तो उसके लिए क्या करेंगे
हम क्या गूगल ट्रांसलेट का उसे करेंगे
गूगल ट्रांसलेट का उसे करेंगे तो मैंने
यहां पे क्लिक किया ओके ट्रांसलेट दिस पेज
बट ट्रांसलेट कर रहा हूं अब एक मिनट
दिखाई दिया अब मैं इसको का रहा हूं
इंग्लिश में ट्रांसलेट करना है किसी भी
लैंग्वेज में ट्रांसलेट कर सकते हो अब
इंग्लिश में ट्रांसलेट कर दिया उसके बाद
ओके इसमें इंग्लिश में ट्रांसलेट कर दिया
अब आपको समझ में ए रहा है की इसमें क्या
है एक न्यूज़ है वॉच फोटो प्रेसिडेंट
पर मैं जो मेट विद किस प्रेसिडेंट
अब मैं इसको जूम कर देता हूं
जो मेरे पास इनफॉरमेशन मिली है मैं यहां
पर लिख रहा हूं
लोकेशन क्या है यहां पर
कंट्रोल
करते हैं और इसमें कोई खास इनफॉरमेशन नहीं
है मतलब हमने क्या है एक इनफॉरमेशन इसमें
कुछ खास क्या है की बड़े-बड़े तीन पिलर्स
हैं ओके तीन बड़े-बड़े पिलर्स हैं उसके
बाद ये रहा उसके बाद कुछ समय दिखाई दे रहा
होगा कुछ चार-पांच क्योंकि बैकग्राउंड का
एनालिसिस करना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है मतलब
एक बहुत बड़ी बिल्डिंग है क्योंकि इतनी
बड़ी
बिल्डिंग है नेक्स्ट ये देखो
सच में काफी बड़ी बिल्डिंग है देखो यहां
पर क्योंकि ये पूरा वो लोकेशन है मतलब ये
रही यहां पर तो मैं हमारे पास कुछ फोटोस
और भी ए गई इसे रिलेटेड मतलब एक एनालिसिस
हमारा अच्छा हो जाएगा अब इसके बेसिस पे एक
फोटो लेक चले थे नेस्ट यहां पर पहुंच गए
ओके के बाद इसके बाद ट्विटर जाते हैं
ट्विटर पर क्या मिलेगा देखो प्रेसिडेंट ओ
वेलकम प्रेसिडेंट हम ओके ये रहा इसमें वही
से इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर मिल गया हमारे पास
और भी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन मिल जाएगी बस ट्विटर
की इनफॉरमेशन नहीं दे काफी ट्विटर में भी
से इनफॉरमेशन है नेक्स्ट इसमें क्या थी अब
हमें ज्यादा वैसे जो है नहीं देखो इसमें
भी एक और एंगल वाला मिल गया देखो एक
थोड़ा-सा बहुत ज्यादा क्लियर मिल गया इसको
भी हम ओपन टाइम ओपन करता हूं देखो यहां पर
भी एक इनफॉरमेशन ये रही मतलब यहां पर कुछ
रखा हुआ है टाइप का क्योंकि इसका एंगल
चेंज हुआ फोटो होगा तो हमारे पास और भी
अलग एंगल से ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के साथ और भी
फोटो होगा कुछ और कुछ मिल गया हमें अब
उसके अलावा इसमें कुछ है
26 अप्रैल 2017
देखो
मैं प्रेसिडेंट प्लेस
ठीक है प्रेसिडेंट लिस्ट किया मैंने कॉपी
उसके बाद में क्या करता हूं
अगर सर्च करते हैं
तो टी यू आर के वाटर
अब देखो
अब हम क्या करें इसको एक कम कर सकते हैं
वैसे चाय तो हम इसको गूगल मैप में भी ओपन
कर सकते हैं मैप में ओपन करते हैं गूगल
मैप चलो
[संगीत]
अलग-अलग फोटो मतलब ये वो प्लेस है जो आपको
दिखाई दे रहा है प्रेजेंट प्लेस है
क्या रे कंफर्म करेंगे लोकेशन वही है या
नहीं है ये देखो ये देखो
कंफर्म कर सकते हैं और कंफर्म कंफर्म
कंफर्म
हो गया
है
हमारे पास लोकेशन
नोट की आपको क्या करना है
डेस्कटॉप वर्जन आपको डाउनलोड कर लीजिए
किसमे अपने मशीन के अंदर अब यहां पर क्या
करते हैं हम सर्च करते हैं यहां पर
कॉन्टिनेंट पेस्ट कर दिया मैंने सर्च
चलो यह हमें मिल गया
अभी क्या होता है
देखना यहां पर यहां पर आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
इसमें कुछ डेस्कटॉप वर्जन लिखा हुआ
डाउनलोड
यहां पर डाउनलोड
होता है मतलब क्या कर सकते हो की प्रेजेंट
लोकेशन बैकग्राउंड लोकेशन दे सकते हो देखो
यहां पर एक ये वाला ऑप्शन
हिस्टोरिकल मतलब क्या अभी लेटेस्ट वाली
क्या साथ 23 तक यही दिखाई दे रही हम क्या
कहते हैं पीछे जा सकते हैं क्या और
एग्जैक्ट कोई क्लियर एंगल हमें दिखाई दे
रहा है इसका और कुछ क्लियर एग्जाम अभी
एंगल इतना ही दिखाई दे रहा है तो हम एक कम
करते हैं पहले इस पे थोड़ा बैक चलते हैं
22 मिनट
देखते हैं और 21 में कुछ और मिले तो एकदम
कर दे कुछ और देखते हैं कुछ और क्लियर
मिलेगा
और देखते हैं
ओके
मतलब
देखो यहां पर कुछ दिखाई जाए मतलब क्या है
वो इमेज ये होगी
पार्ट निकाल के आया है मतलब की इसके
बिल्डिंग से थोड़ा सा बाहर यहां की हो
शक्ति है वो यहां पे कुछ अवेलेबल है वैसे
क्या कोई कैमरा अवेलेबल है इसमें चेक कर
सकते हैं आप
स्टेटमेंट अवेलेबल है
मतलब यह क्या है ये रहा अगर आपको चेक
करोगे यहां पर क्या है की
कंफर्म कर का रहे हैं देखो अब मैं क्या
करता हूं यहां पर हाईलाइट करता हूं और
यहां पे क्या कॉन्टिनेंट लेट हूं
यह पिंक करता हूं मैं इसको डिलीट को और 1
मिनट कैसे भी और क्लियर है यह थोड़ा सा और
क्लियर ठीक है
जो लोकेशन
यह आउटर पार्ट निकाला तो मतलब की जो यह
यहां पर हो सकता है क्योंकि एक हमारे पास
इमेज भी है इमेज कौन-कौन से हैं हमारे पास
देखो
इमेज है मतलब ये इमेज है दूसरा क्या आउटर
इमेज ये है इसकी बजाई का कौन-कौन सी इमेज
ये रही है ये वही वो वही वाला पार्ट है तो
आपको दिखाई दे रहा है अगर आप इसको देखें
हम आउटसाइड ओके और उसके बाद हमारे पास
गूगल में भी कंफर्म करते ही रहेगा और गूगल
से हम कंफर्म करते ही रहा अब इसको हम जूम
करके देखते हैं तो भी हमें क्या मतलब ये
रहा वो इमेज के आगे थोड़ा सा एक पार्ट ये
था मतलब एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन हमें मिल गई
कोऑर्डिनेटर कौन से हम अगर बोले एग्जिट
कोऑर्डिनेटर कौन से हमारे लोकेशन के यहां
पर बोल सकते हैं यहां पर यहां पर कुछ वो
कोऑर्डिनेटर है क्योंकि इसके थ्रू हमने ये
कंफर्म किया है की जो लोकेशन होगी वो यहां
पर होगी और वो तीन पिलर्स यहां पे दिखाई
दे रहे हैं इनके बीच में कोई एन कोई ये
हुआ क्योंकि गार्डन भी आपको दिखाई दे रहे
हैं ये रहा ये रहा हमारा उसके बाद ये
इनफॉरमेशन है हमारे पास हो गया नेक्स्ट
हमारे पास ये था उसके बाद आपको अगर और
ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के साथ ये थी थोड़ा सा और
हमारे पास कुछ इनफॉरमेशन कहां से आई थी
यहां से आई थी कौन सा था ये रहा देखो यहां
से वो दो एक दो तीन पीली यहां वाली
इनफॉरमेशन है तो बेसिकली हमारे पास क्या
है
एग्जिट को डिलीट ही ए गए हमारे पास एग्जिट
कोऑर्डिनेट्स हमारे पास ए गए तो प्लेस का
नाम क्या है प्रेजेंट प्लेस और वह जगह कौन
सी है जो हमने लिखी थी जगह हमारे पास ये
है प्रेग्नेंट प्लेस और लोकेशन है अंकारा
अगर इसके बाद अगर एग्जैक्ट कोऑर्डिनेटर भी
अगर यहां पर मेंशन करना जो इसका आंसर है
हमारा तो ये है हमारे पास ये है ये एग्जिट
कोऑर्डिनेटर हो सकते हैं यहां पर यहां पर
कहानी की ये इमेज हो शक्ति है अगर मैं
यहां देखो
गूगल में और गूगल मैप और ये एग्जिट
कोऑर्डिनेटर मेरे कुछ यहां के हो सकते हैं
तो ये वो कोऑर्डिनेट्स है मेरे अगर मैं
बात करूं तो मुझे एग्जैक्ट कोऑर्डिनेटर
चाहिए थे तो ये वो कोऑर्डिनेट्स हैं जो
जहां पर वह दोनों हैंडसेट कर रहे थे
अकॉर्डिंग तू दिस इमेज तो यह था अगर
काली मशीन है
यहां पर मुझे पहले क्या करें
हमारे पास यह फोटो ए गई अब मैं क्या करता
हूं इसको डेस्कटॉप पर मेरी
टेक्स्ट ऑफ करता हूं हमारे पास कोई इमेज
ओके
फाइन
बेटा क्लियर कर दिया जाता है अभी कोई भी
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है
गूगल मैप में
उसे करते हो इसलिए उसे किया जाता है
स्ट्रीट व्यू है ही नहीं यहां पर कहानी
दिखाई दे नहीं था मुझे तो क्योंकि मैंने
क्लिक किया यहां पर आसपास में कुछ भी नहीं
है स्टेट में अगर हम देखते भी हैं तो
स्टेट व्यू है नहीं यहां पर अगर ये टेंपल
की इमेज है अभी तक कुछ भी नहीं दिखाई दे
रहा है आपको क्या फोटो से दास दास लाइन
कुछ भी नहीं है पर अभी अगर यहां देखें जाए
तो अभी तक इसमें देखिए यहां पर है इतना है
बट यहां पर नहीं है अगर मैं चाहूं तो इसका
देख सकता हूं अगर ये कुछ दिखाएगा क्या
ये कहां का है
प्रेसिडेंट पहले इसका नहीं है
अगर देखेंगे तो यह वाला नहीं है क्योंकि
हमने बहुत दूर से लिया है
इसलिए क्या है
एक मिनट ए गया
यह लोकेशन
या 360 कैमरा कोई भी इसके आसपास नहीं है
जो इसको क्या करेगा एक्सपोज करेगा
तो अभी चलो स्टेट व्यू का बात चल गई है तो
आपको बताता हूं की स्टूडियो के टॉपिक क्या
होता है तो कुछ है मैप्स मैं आपको लिस्ट
बताता हूं जो अभी ध्यान से सुना
क्लियर करते हैं क्योंकि हमें जो लैब बैंड
थी हम सॉल्व कर चुके हैं की लेबल में क्या
था की हमें दो चीज
फाइंड आउट करनी थी
की 1 मिनट ओके
पीछे पीछे चलो
हमारे पास दोनों ऑप्शंस मिल चुके हैं
इसलिए क्या है हम इसकी चिंता करने की जरूर
नहीं है अभी मैं बात करता हूं स्टेट में
होगी देखो क्या होता है की
1 मिनट वेज मैं नोट्स
बताने वाला था ओके अब क्या होता है
इसके पास काफी बड़ा डाटा है इसके पास एक
और होता है एप्पल मैप्स वो भी आपको काफी
अच्छा है 3d के टर्म में किट में दिखता है
काफी अच्छा एक कौन सा है आपका दूसरा
गूगल मैप हो गया फर्स्ट तो एक आपका होता
है होता है एप्पल मैप जो अपल्स डिवाइस उसे
करते है ना एप्पल मैप्स यहां पे ऐसे
एक्सेस होगा नहीं वैसे ही एप्पल मैप्स
लेकिन क्या अपल्स के डिवाइसेज हैं उसमें
भी काफी अच्छी गूगल से ज्यादा क्लेरिटी
मिलती है सम टाइम्स एक आपका एक और चीज
बताओ मैं एक और होता है आपका एक होता है
लिखिए एम ए पी पी डबल
मैप होता है अगर इसको सर्च करोगे
तो ये फर्स्ट वाला जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा
है
इसको क्या है की फेसबुक के द्वारा ऑन किया
गया है ये क्या करता है की इसके पास भी
काफी कुछ डाटा है सम टाइम्स क्या होगा कुछ
ऐसे स्टेट में होंगे कुछ ऐसे
गूगल मैप से अवेलेबल नहीं होंगे कुछ ऐसे
जगह होंगे जहां पर गूगल मैप्स निकाल लेकिन
क्या फेसबुक तो कम करती है तो फेसबुक का
भी ये खुद का ये डाटा बेस है जिसको आप उसे
कर सकते हो
अभी मैं मैप पर जाता हूं तो इसमें भी काफी
अच्छा डाटा है
यह देखो यह सर के साथ जो ग्रीन वाला पार्ट
है स्टूडियो से रिलेटेड है अब मैं इसमें
क्या सर्च करता हूं
उसमें कुछ अवेलेबल है
प्रेसिडेंट प्लेस था ना हमारे पास
आज
ओ पी उसके बाद क्या इससे रिलेटेड
नहीं करवा रहा
इसके पहले हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा
सर्च करता हूं किसी भी कंट्री पे जाकर मैं
पर एग्जांपल अपनी इंडिया में चलते हैं हम
इंडियन प्रोग्राम दिल्ली में चलते हैं तो
यहां पर देखो काफी अच्छा आपको काफी ज्यादा
डाटा मिलेगा आपको देखो दिल्ली रे पूरा
ग्रीन हो रखा है देखो ग्रीन हो रखा ग्रीन
ग्रीन ये रहा पर एग्जांपल मैं कहानी का भी
ले जो नई दिल्ली में कोई भी मैंने पैनोरमा
देखना है क्योंकि ये पैनोरमास है मैंने
कोई यहां पे क्लिक किया यहां पर काफी
अच्छे से आपको मिल जाएगा देखो जैसे मैंने
यहां पे क्लिक किया
देखो काफी अच्छा डिटेल में आपको मिलेगा
अगर मैं इसको चला देता हूं तो जिसने जी
हिसाब से फोटो लिया हुआ है उसे हिसाब से
इसमें चला रहेगा कंटिन्यू
देखो ये पूरा पूरा यहां पर जो आपको दिखाई
दे रहा है कहानी पर रॉक सकते हैं आप पर
एग्जांपल भी सकते हो
करके देख सकते हो की किसने कौनसा फोटो कब
लिया होगा देखो यह रहा
इसने क्या कर रहा है की अपना जो भी आप
फोटो डालते हो उसके बेस पे भी डाटा किसने
कलेक्ट कर रखा देखो काफी अच्छा डाटा भी है
इसका भी कम बैक जाता हूं मैं इससे तो इस
तरीके से देखो जरा तो एक ये है इसको आप
उसे कर सकते हो क्योंकि आप फेसबुक यूजर्स
हो तो मैं तो फेसबुक यूजर नहीं हूं तो और
एक और है की काफी अच्छा है
यह इंडेक्स ए ए एन दी ए एक्स ये इंडेक्स
मैप्स भी करके होता है और हां एक ये
इंडेक्स मैप्स है मैं इसको अगर सर्च करता
हूं देखो इस पे इस पे भी काफी अच्छा डाटा
मिल जाता है सम टाइम्स और सम टाइम्स ने भी
मिलता लेकिन आजकल सबसे ज्यादा गूगल मैप्स
भी मिल जाता है तो एक ये इंडेक्स है तो
अभी देखो इसमें भी कुछ डाटा मिल जाएगा
लेकिन आपको यहां और भी कुछ जैसे बिजनेस
टाइम ओके
लेकिन
अगर आप देखोगे क्लिक करके
आप देखने को देख सकते हो बट यहां पर देख
सकते हो सड़क देखो काफी अच्छा इसमें
क्लेरिटी इसमें काफी अच्छा देखो आगे चलोगे
आगे चल सकते हो आप
देखो
कहां से देखो पेड़ पौधे यह पेड़ पौधे इस
तरीके से हम क्या है यह इनफॉरमेशन
के अलावा एक और होता है
देखो ये पूरा पूरा चीन के लेटेड आपको का
काफी अगर मैप्स ओपन ये ओपन ही नहीं हो रहा
ये ओपन ही नहीं हो रहा क्योंकि ये क्या है
चीन के काफी अच्छी
क्वालिटी के साथ क्या है बिल्डिंग सबको
दिखता है ये इसमें ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन
तो करके दे सकता हूं क्योंकि उन्होंने
शायद बन करके
एक्सप्लोरर इमेजरी ओके देखो
इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल है
इसके पास भी काफी अच्छा डाटा है अगर स्टेट
में उसका भी देखोगे इसमें शायद मैंने अभी
थोड़ा सा क्या है इसका मैं ज्यादा क्लियर
नहीं हूं बट मेरे पास इसकी है ये
इनफॉरमेशन है की इसमें शायद है ओपन स्टेट
मैप इसमें ओपन स्टेट मैप करके भी एक कुछ
भी बहुत साड़ी चीज हैं इसमें भी ओपन करोगे
तो यहां पर भी कुछ मिल जाता है ओपन स्टेट
मैप में भी अगर मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
इसको मैंने ज्यादा उसे नहीं किया जाता मैं
गूगल अर्थ हो गया गूगल मैप हो गया और ये
आपका जो है फेसबुक वाला है ये है तो बाकी
ये क्या है की आप चाहोगे लिस्ट अपने पास
रख सकते हो ये साड़ी वो लिस्ट है मैप्स की
इन सब की जो आपको दिखाई दे रही होगी हां
एक और चीज बताता हूं आपको इमेज रिवर्सल
इमेज रिवर्सल से रिलेटेड
त्रिकोण से कर सकते हो इमेज रिवर्स सर्च
मैं आपको स्टार्टिंग से बताना चाहता हूं
टैक्सटाइल्स वन तो होगी हमारी सबको ये
बताओ पहले आपको अभी तक समझ में ए रहा है
जो कुछ होता है
मजा ए रहा है या ऐसे ही ऊपर से जा रहा है
यस या नो बता दीजिए बर हो रहे हो या जो भी
हो रहे हो उसके बाद बताता हूं की आप कोई
गूगल इमेज रिवर्स सर्च कितने कितने तरीके
से कर सकते हो
ठीक है देखो एक चीज हमारी यहां पर क्लियर
हो गया अभी मेरे को क्लोज कर देता हूं
जितनी इनफॉरमेशन हमें मिल रही है ऐसे ही
आप भी कलेक्ट कर सकते हो तो यह तरीका होता
है
एक तो ये तरीका बता दिया मैंने एक चीज याद
रखना देखो एक और तरीका होता है
इसको जब ओपन करोगे तो इसके अंदर भी क्या
कर सकते हो आप
इसके अंदर भी कर सकते हो आप इंडेक्स ओके
इंडेक्स ए गया
इंडेक्स इंडेक्स इमेज ओके इमेज
आपको प्रोवाइड करता है यहां पर सिलेक्ट
कीजिए ओपन और ये देखना ये भी काफी अच्छे
रिजल्ट्स आपको प्रोवाइड करता है उसे बैटरी
रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड करता देखो ये इमेज इसमें
इसने और भी ज्यादा क्लेरिटी देखो इसमें और
भी ज्यादा रिजल्ट आपके साथ साथ छोड़ के ये
देखो इसमें क्या ऑप्शन ये भी है की आप इसी
में इसी के हिसाब से क्या का सकते हो वो
कर सकते हो तो अब ये देखो इसमें आपकी
लैंग्वेज में कर दिया उसने क्या है इसके
हिसाब से पता लगा लिया की कौन सी लैंग्वेज
में होगा इसके भी आपको देखो यह लैंग्वेज
अगर इसको आपको कैसे समझ में तो ए नहीं रहे
हो क्या है देखो
कितना अच्छा स्मूथ कम करता है देखो मैंने
इस पर क्लिक किया जस्ट इनफॉरमेशन पर अलसो
देखो इस पे क्लिक किया तो देखो ट्रक की
काफी अच्छा प्लेस की और भी काफी और इमेज ए
गई आपके पास देखो यहां पर ये इतनी साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन एक्चुअल में हमारे पास थे नहीं
वो इमेज आपको इतनी ज्यादा क्लेरिटी वाली
इमेज नहीं थी जैसे प्रोग्राम ये देखा हूं
आगे देखो ये और भी ज्यादा क्लियर इमेज है
उससे ये रही तो देखो ये ज्यादा इसमें इसके
पास इनफॉरमेशन है तो अगर मैं इसको क्या
करता हूं अगर इसको राइट क्लिक करता हूं
इसको मैं ओपन न्यू तब करूंगा नहीं ओपन
न्यू तब कर देता हूं अगर आपको पता करना है
की ये क्या लिखा हुआ है तो सिंपली क्या
करो जाइए इसको और इसको सिंपली क्या करना
है कॉपी करना है ना ये ट्रांसलेट के साथ
गूगल ट्रांसलेट के साथ ओपन कर दीजिए ये का
ट्रांसलेट करके इंग्लिश में आपको दे देगा
इसमें लिखा हुआ है देखो तो इतना हेल्पफुल
है आपके लिए क्या ये ये ट्रांसलेट करना
ट्रांसलेट कितना हेल्पफुल हुआ आपके लिए
ओके कितना हेल्पफुल है आप लोगों के लिए
देखिए तो इससे आपका पता चल गया ये इंडेक्स
में काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको सर्च करने
हैं देखो ये रहा ये क्या करता है की जिसकी
मैं बात कर रहा था देखो अकेला फलक के बेस
पे भी पता कर सकते हैं देखो फ्लैग के लिए
भी उसने क्या है उसे मेंशन कर देखो इसको
ये फ्लैग किसका है इसने देखो इस पे क्लिक
इसने कुछ मेंशन किया अब इनके ऊपर कुछ आया
नहीं है ये रहा तो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है
क्रॉप कर सकते हैं इसमें और भी ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हैं देखो ये इंडेक्स
इंडेक्स के सर्च करके भी काफी कुछ बहुत
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हैं ऊपर से
क्या कर सकता है की ये आईडेंटिफाई कर लेट
हूं चीजों को आपके फोर गण बैकग्राउंड को
अगर मिलती है तो आपके सामने यहां पर
रिजल्ट में शो करता है इस की लैंग्वेज के
हिसाब से पेपर क्या होता है की आपके किसी
फोटो में पिक्चर में क्या है अगर कोई
टेक्स्ट लिखा हो तो टेक्स्ट को हम क्या
करता है ये गैस करने की कोशिश करता है और
आपकी स्क्रीन को साइड में राइट में आपको
दिखता है तो काफी इंडेक्स भी है एक ये
तरीका है दूसरा क्या है प्लगइन होता है एक
दूसरा क्या है प्लगइन कौन सा उसे प्लगइन
का नाम है
और एक न्यूज़
एक न्यूज़ प्लगइन इसको क्या कर लीजिए आप
लॉगिन को एड कर लीजिए फेक न्यूज़
एड कर लीजिए उसके बाद क्या है की आपको
इमेज को डाउनलोड करने की जरूर नहीं होगी
पर एग्जांपल मेरे पास पहुंची मिलती है तो
मैं इसको क्या कर सकता हूं अब मैं वेबसाइट
पे चला हूं जहां से मैंने इसे इमेज को
लेना था और एक एग्जांपल वो वेबसाइट है ये
रही क्योंकि मुझे इस वाली इमेज को करना है
बस सिंपली क्या करूंगा जब ये वाला प्लगइन
है देखो ये ध्यान से देखो क्लिक करो उसमें
फेक न्यूज़ दीपम कर करके मारोगे तो ये
उसमें ए जाएगा सर्च इंजन में तो यहां पर
एड तू क्रोम कीजिए दें उसके बाद क्या करना
है यहां पर जाइए राइट क्लिक कीजिए यहां पर
ऑप्शंस ए रहे हैं देखो एक न्यूज़ वाला
इसका प्लगइन एड हो गया यहां पे देखो जिसके
साथ करना चाहते हो इमेज मैग्नीफायर इमेज
फॉरेंसिक इमेज रिवर्स सर्च सभी के साथ
करना चाहते हो ओनली गूगल के साथ गूगल लेंस
के साथ ये टेक्स्ट के साथ विंग के साथ
बेडरूम के साथ रेडित के साथ सबके साथ करना
तो यहां पे सीधा अभी मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा सिंपली मैं राइट क्लिक कर दिया
इसके बाद क्या ये ओपन कर दिया देखो आपको
ड्रग ड्रॉप करने की जरूर नहीं है वही
इनफॉरमेशन आपकी स्क्रीन पे सामने इसमें शो
कर दिया तो काफी अच्छा है ये आप अपनी
उसमें उसके साथ उसे कर सकते हो बात करता
हूं एग्जिट डाटा की अब एग्जिट डाटा कैसे
कैसे निकाल सकते हो एग्जिट डाटा की स्वागत
करता हूं पर एग्जांपल मेरे पास एक इमेज
चाहिए
मेरे पास इमेज है एक तरीका ही आता है की
इस पर राइट क्लिक कीजिए और उसके बाद इसकी
प्रॉपर्टीज में जाइए इसके बाद प्रॉपर्टी
बताता हूं कहां पर मेरे पास की प्रॉपर्टीज
ओके मैं बस इसकी इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है मेरे
पास यहां पर है तो यहां पर क्लिक
प्रॉपर्टीज मैं आपको क्या मिल रहा है कुछ
ज्यादा नहीं है 16 जुलाई मतलब क्या है की
आज ही नहीं की क्योंकि हमने किया है इसका
साइज ये है ये ये बात मतलब क्या की एक इस
पांच छह आई हुई है क्योंकि ये हमने इसको
डाउनलोड किया हुआ है कई बार यहां पर क्या
है काफी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने में मिलती
है जब भी कोई फोटो होती है आप क्या करता
है राइट क्लिक करते हो ना तो पापा क्या
करने का मां था आपको काफी इनफॉरमेशन देखने
को मिलती है की ये फोटो कहां से ली गई है
की इस कैमरा से ली गई है क्या इसके जिओ
कोऑर्डिनेटर अगर लोकेशन शेर की गई हो तो
आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हो
आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हो उसके बाद क्या हुआ
की ये हो गया उसके बाद एक प्लगइन है एक
प्लगइन इसके लिए भी प्लगइन है एक दो तीन
प्लगइन बता दिया मैंने एक और प्लगइन है एक
प्लगइन इसका है एग्जिट डाटा के लिए एग्जिट
डाटा अगर देखना चाहते हैं उसके लिए भी लगे
ना आता है उसे प्लगइन का नाम है आपका एक
मिनट मुझे दीजिए कहा गया मेरा प्लगइन का
नाम लिखा था यार
एग्जिट
विवर
प्रो यह वाला आता है
तो पर एग्जांपल कैसे इस प्लगइन का कम किया
जाता है तो मैं आपको एग्जैक्ट डेट है
जिसका देखने इमेज का कोई एग्जांपल मेरे
पास एक इमेज थी कहां पर होगी ये रही ये
मेरे थी राइट क्लिक किया यहां पर क्या कर
सकते हैं देखो सो एक्जीबिट आप करोगे राइट
क्लिक कीजिए बता दिया की आपके पास क्या है
देखो प्रभु इनफॉरमेशन हमने एग्जिट उससे
मिली इंस्टाग्राम से कुछ नहीं मिलेगा ये
रहा यहां पर भी आपको क्या है वो एग्जिट
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी देखो
किस लोकेशन से आई है ये इस वेबसाइट का नाम
है इमेज का साइज क्या है बस इतना ही
क्योंकि इसका एक जीव डाटा है ही नहीं
एक्चुअल में बैटरी भी देख सकते हैं ये रहा
अगर कुछ भी किसी भी इमेज डाटा होगा तो ये
भी आपको क्या है काफी हेल्प कर सकता है
आपको दिखा देगा तो ये भी एक अच्छा प्लगइन
है तो एक मैंने आपको बता दिया ट्रांसलेट
कर लीजिए दूसरा आपको एग्जिट डाटा वाला
प्लगइन एड कर लीजिए उसके बाद एक न्यूज़
वाला लेकिन एड कर लीजिए तो ये दो तीन
प्लगइन है ये एड कर लीजिए अभी तक के लिए
ये बताइए अभी तक का जो मैंने करवाया आप
लोगों को समझ में आया या नहीं आया बताओ
तो गूगल इमेज रिवर्स सर्च करने
अच्छा है उससे बेहतरीन रिजल्ट मिलता है तो
हमेशा क्या करो अपनी जो इनफॉरमेशन को
क्रॉस चेक करो एक इनफॉरमेशन के ऊपर कभी भी
डिपेंडेंट ना रहे उसके बाद मैंने उसका
प्लगइन भी बताया है और उसके बाद राइट
क्लिक उसके बाद रिवर्स भी कर सकते हैं ऐसे
तो कई बार क्या इसी इमेज के साथ रिवर्स
सर्च भी कर सकते हो सर्च विद गूगल भी करते
हो क्योंकि आजकल एडवांस है ना तो ऐसे भी
कर सकते हो तो एक रिवर सर्च का ऑप्शन यह
बताया एग्जिट डाटा का मैंने आपको क्लियर
कर दिया है उसके बाद एक इंपॉर्टेंट
इनफॉरमेशन बताता हूं आपको इंपॉर्टेंट
इनफॉरमेशन क्या है की इंपॉर्टेंट
इनफॉरमेशन क्या होता है की आपको क्या है
गूगल गूगल वर्किंग आई है आपको गूगल
वर्किंग मैंने आपको सिखाया है तो गूगल
वर्किंग कैसे करते पर एग्जांपल
मैंने कुछ भी सर्च करना है तो उसका नाम
लिखा और एक चीज मैं आपको एग्जांपल देखा
दिखता हूं कहां गया मेरा एक एग्जांपल मैं
आपको ये आपके लिए रेडी किया था वो
एग्जांपल मैं एग्जांपल वेयर इस मी
एग्जांपल
ओके डी पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
ट्रांसलेट रहा ना हिंदी इंग्लिश ट्रांसलेट
निकाल सकते हो किसी भी चीज की कोई
एग्जांपल मेरे पास एक फेमस जैसे एम ओ यू
एन एम ओ ए के फेमस वो है एक वैली का नाम
है
अगर मैं इसको सर्च करता हूं
तो यह इसकी इनफॉरमेशन डालिए
तो मैं क्या कर सकता हूं आप मुझे क्या
स्मारक पहले की वो क्या होता है की ये वो
इमेज होगी तो प्रेजेंट होगी कुछ इमेज 2016
नैरो डॉ हो गया 2016 का बट क्या आपको लगता
है की ये कुछ आपको फिर भी समझ में नहीं ए
रहा तो अब क्या कर सकते हो इसको नेट ऑन
करने के लिए आपके पास एक यहां जाइए टूल्स
है स्पेशल है एनीटाइम जा के और कस्टम रेंज
सेट कर सकते हो मैं आपको बताया था ये यहां
पर सेट कर सकते हो आप कौन सा किस पैटर्न
में करते हैं यहां पर ये होता है आपका
पैटर्न होता है
आपको पता है
पहले
रहती है
फरवरी से करना चाहता हूं तो मैं इधर से कर
लूंगा एक मिनट
यार कुछ है
उसके बाद में क्या करना चाहता हूं
मार्च 2001
नीमच 2016
[संगीत]
ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या 1 एयर एगो यह होगा
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है अब यहां पर
फिल्टर ऑप्शन होता है यहां पर क्या की बस
ओनली दिस एयर तक मतलब की युटुब पे भी कुछ
खास डाटा है नहीं बट क्या मैं कैसे कर
सकता हूं अभी मैं क्या कर सकता हूं ठीक है
मेरे पास फिल्टर मैंने अप्लाई किया हुआ है
फिल्टर मैंने अप्लाई किया हुआ है एक तो
ऊपर से क्या है की मैं इसको कैसे सर्च कर
सकता हूं मैं आपको पहले बता देता हूं
मैंने साइड क्या है साइड उसके बाद
youtube.com youtube.com
youtube.com और उसके बाद क्या किया मैंने
नेक्स्ट उसका शब्द का नाम क्या था वर्ल्ड
का नाम
youtube.com और वर्ल्ड का नाम था
ट्रांसलेट कर सकते हैं
सर आप ऐसे कर सकते हो मतलब कितना आपका
नैरो डॉ कर सकते
हो अपने उसको अगर आपने कोंबो उसे कर लिया
किसी भी सर्चिंग पैटर्न में गूगल डोर का
उसे करके प्लस में अगर आपने जो गूगल
ट्रांसलेटर है अगेन इन दोनों को आपने
कोंबो उसे किया ना तो आपको मैं बता रहा
हूं मजा ए जाएगा आप किसी भी सर्चिंग मोदी
जी बना सकते हो क्योंकि कितना भी पेस्ट
में जा सकते हो कितना भी कर सकते हो देखो
अब कितना नया होगा साथ में क्या है पर
एग्जांपल कोई अदर लैंग्वेज में सर्च करना
हो आपके साथ बहुत आसन कम हो जाएगा पर
एग्जांपल इसको किसी भी एंगल ट्रांसलेट
करके देखोगे हो सकता है की कई बार आपके
सामने क्या चीज आएंगे की कुछ ऐसे रिजल्ट
होते हैं जो इंग्लिश में कम आते हैं बट
क्या है की वो जिसमें भाषा से रिलेटेड
होगा जो रिजल्ट होगा क्योंकि जब आप
इन्वेस्टिगेशन करोगे तो आपको एक आइडिया
मिल जाएगा की मिल जाएगी हां यहां का तो
यहां की एक लैंग्वेज होती है तो कई बार
क्या होता है की लोकल लैंग्वेज में
ज्यादातर और ज्यादा एग्जैक्ट चीज मिलती
हैं आपको की किसकी बजे इंग्लिश की बजे तो
आप क्या करोगे अब आपको वो तो मिलेंगे
बताते ही नहीं जर्मन फ्रांस और से कुछ भी
तो क्या करोगे गूगल ट्रांसलेट का उसे करते
हो उसे इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करोगे तो आप बैटरी बादल सकते क्योंकि यहां
क्या करोगे इसकी जगह क्या कर डॉग किसी भी
माउंटेन मेरे को मेरे कॉपी किया और मैं
सिंपली इसको क्या करता हूं पहले इसको
ट्रांसलेट कर दो ट्रांसलेट
मुझे
लक्ष्मी करना है
तो ऐसे क्या
है इसकी लैंग्वेज को क्या कर डन यहां पर
सीधा सिंपली रख दो गूगल डॉल्फिन के साथ तो
आपके रिजल्ट आपके ज्यादा बटर आएंगे तो मैं
बता रहा हूं की अगर आपको गूगल वर्किंग
प्लस इनका अगर ट्रांसलेटर का कोंबो उसे
करना ए गया ना तो मजा आया आप लोगों को सच
में बहुत ज्यादा मजा आएगा तो एक कम करते
हैं आज सेशन इतना ही रखते हैं काफी लंबा
हो गया या मजा ए रहा आगे चल रहा है
क्योंकि ओनली ₹715 हो गया है
ऑलरेडी 7:15 हो गया बताओ
तो आज इतना ही करें
और वेरी हैप्पी की कुछ लोग हमारे साथ 23
है वेरी थैंक यू
बताओ बताओ जल्दी से
यस नो यस नो यस
फिर
एक कम करते हैं क्या करते हैं
[संगीत]
मैं इमेज का क्या
जाता है
तो आप लोगों के लिए टास्क है
ठीक है आप लोगों के लिए टास्क है
टास्क देख लीजिए स्क्रीन पर क्या है यह
आपको एक फोटो दिया हुआ है
ओके तो फिर है नेक्स्ट वह इमेज का इमेज
आपके सामने यह रही है
आपको आपके ग्रुप में यह स्क्रीनशॉट आपको
यह मिल जाएगी यह मैच आपके ग्रुप में सेंड
कर दी जाएगी
हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर इस पर जाइए एक
लिंक है सर्च कीजिए यह वाला आगे आपको ये
युटुब पर सर्च कर सकते हैं क्या आपके शेर
कर सकता हूं क्या मैं शेर नहीं कर सकता
आपका ग्रुप में मिल जाएगा एडरवाइज यहां पर
जाइए आपको क्या लिंक यहां पर चाहिए
उसमें जाइए और आपका जो एक्सरसाइज
है प्लीज डोंट उसे डी आंसर
अगर आप चाहोगे तो यहां पर चीटिंग कर सकते
हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बट यह देखो यह
टास्क जो आपको दिया टॉस नंबर 7 एक्सरसाइज
नंबर 7 जो आपको करनी है
वैसे उन्होंने आंसर भी दिया है यहां पर
इन्होंने क्या किया राइटर भी लिखा है
प्लीज अगर प्रैक्टिस करनी है तो राइट अप
के थ्रू ना जाइए
भाई एक कम करो जो फर्स्ट दे हमारी जो
वीडियो है ना फर्स्ट जब हमने अनाउंसमेंट
किया था कब अनाउंसमेंट किया था जब हमने
अनाउंसमेंट किया था की हम स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं तो प्लीज एक बार हमारे डिपॉजिट
अकादमी के उसे पे जाइए युटुब चैनल पर जाइए
प्लेलिस्ट में जाइए वहां पर हमने जब
अनाउंस किया था एक दो ढाई मिनट का वीडियो
है जिसमें अपना नाम किया था की हम
क्वेश्चन पढ़ना वाले हैं
वेडनेसडे से 12 तारीख से तो उसके लिंक
वहां पर लिंक दिया हुआ है की ट्विटर का
वाटर ट्विटर बजा के आप ग्रुप में एड हो
सकते हैं ओके टेलीग्राम ग्रुप पर तो यह
देखिए यहां से क्या कर सकते हो ये वो
टास्क है यहां पे वो क्वेश्चन है इनके
आंसर के रिपोर्ट रेडी रखिए ओके आपका यह
टास्क है आज सेशन और करेंगे और चलो एक कम
करते हैं की आप लोगों को चलो मजा ए रहा है
तो मुझे अभी आप लोगों के सामने अगर मैं
ग्रुप में पाल मिलेगा पाल रन करूंगा
गोल्डन करवाऊंगी मैं कल के लिए जितने लोग
उसमें
पार्टिसिपेट करेंगे तो मैं कल आपके लिए
सेशन रख सकता हूं ओपन सोशल टेलिजेंस इमेज
इमेज एनालिसिस का कल कर सकता हूं क्योंकि
एक लंबा टॉपिक है इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक मुझे
पता है उसमें मुझे कुछ और आपको क्या है
लैब सॉल्व करके दिखानी थी टारगेट मेरा कुछ
और लैब किया था बट क्या की आपको समझने के
लिए थोड़ा सा आई बिल टेक टाइम तथा'एस वही
की अगर आप लोग चाहे तो हम क्या कर सकते
हैं कल एक सेशन रख सकते हैं ओपन सोशल
इंटेलिजेंस इसी पे कंटिन्यू अगर आप चाहते
हो उसके लिए आपको बोल रन किया किया जाएगा
गोल्डन में मुझे मिनिमम 30 स्टूडेंट चाहिए
मिनिमम 30 चाहिए जैसे आज 27 है मुझे 30
चाहिए लाइव में अगर एक भी कम हुआ कल तो
देखो लाइव सेशन में कल कम हुआ तो उसके बाद
देखना आपका सेशन डेली हो जाएगा ओबवियसली
नहीं तो मैं क्या कर सकता हूं कल सेशन ले
सकता हूं आप लोगों का वो सेंड का बट आपको
पॉल रन होगा तो बोल रहा हूं आपको जल्दी से
मिल जाएगा आपके ट्विटर ग्रुप में तो वहां
पर जाइए और आपको क्या करना है वहां पे पाल
में सिलेक्ट कीजिए की आप कल सेशन चाहते हो
या नहीं चाहते अगर कल मैक्सिमम लोगों को
आया तो मैं कल आपका ओसियन का सेशन लाइव
प्लेन करवा दूंगा और इसी से कंटिन्यू
करेंगे फिर से इंटरेस्टिंग बट मुझे मिनिमम
इतने तो चाहिए अगर ज्यादा लेकर ए सकते तो
लेक आई बताओ पहले तो जो चाट में बता दीजिए
की चाहते हो कल सेशन उसके बाद पोलिंग
करवाऊंगी मैं
बताइए
30 स्टूडेंट मिलेंगे मेरे को
ठीक है आपको एक कम कीजिए की आपको जल्दी से
आज ग्रुप में गोल्डन मिल जाएगा कल के लिए
कितने लोग चाहते हैं इस के बेस पर आपका
सेशन डिलीवरी किया जाएगा मैक्सिमम लोग
चाहिए बट एक और कंडीशन उसके लिए की जैसे
ही आपका सेशन शेड्यूल कर दिया जाएगा तो
मुझे तभी मेक सर होगा जब वो सेशन शेड्यूल
होने के बाद लाइक हो जाएगा
तो आपके फोन पर डिपेंड करेगा अगर कल अच्छा
है तो सेशन हम शेड्यूल कर देंगे कल
मॉर्निंग में कल मॉर्निंग में अगर सेशन
शेड्यूल हुआ तो मुझे उसे पर सेशन स्टार्ट
होने से पहले जैसे की जैसे आप सेशन
नोटिफिकेशन मिलेगा आप लोगों की मुझे लाइक
चाहिए जितने आने वाले हैं सभी के लाइक
चाहिए तो यहां 2327 लोग थे तो 30 लाइक तो
मुझे चाहिए बिफोर स्टार्टिंग
शेड्यूल कर दिया मुझे लेना होगा उसके बाद
आगे वाले सेशन में डिले कर दूंगा और
कंटेंट डिलीवरी फिर आप लोगों को डिपेंड हो
जाएगी ओके तो आज का सेशन क्या करते हैं हम
और करते हैं बाय बाय गुड दे
और थैंक यू
सपोर्ट करने के लिए तो जल्दी से लाइक
सब्सक्राइब कीजिए और कमेंट करके कमेंट
करना मत भूलिए अगर आप लोगों को अच्छा लगा
है और लिंकडइन पर जाइए हमारे
पेज पर और वहां पे जाके भी जल्दी से लाइक
सब्सक्राइब करना मत भूलिए ओके
तुम्हारा यार दे आफ्टर टुमारो डिड